to be a dreamer you got to be a little
bit batshit crazy dude you gotta be a
little different than everybody else Not
only was he completely different than
any fighter we've ever seen but he
fought tooth and nail from nothing to
become the single-handedly most powerful
fighter to ever compete in the UFC it's
not even remotely close name a fighter
who's your favorite you're Mount
Rushmore none of them hold a candle to
Conor McGregor and the influence and
power that he had over Dana White in the
UFC when you watch the doc you realize
they are Partners everybody else is just
a subcontracted fighter Connor you can
see in this doc they are Partners it's
insane dude it will never be done again
he changed the game forever you've got
to respect that